hello and welcome my name is stephen
fluin
i'm a developer advocate on the angular
team here at google
my job is really fun because i get to
help developers be successful with
angular
and i get to spend a lot of time
listening and engaging with the
community
so we can reflect your needs onto the
team one things that we've learned
having worked with a lot of developers
across the world is that
staying up to date is really really
important and so
today's talk is all about how to keep
your application as fast as possible and
as fresh as possible
using angular we're going to be diving
into some of the best practices that you
should be following as an application
developer
and we'll take a look at live code and
see how you can actually go in and debug
and build your application out
so let's actually get started so if we
take a look at what we've got here
this is a application that i've built
using the angular cli
so it's a very very basic application
this should look very very familiar
it's basically we ran ng-new and we
installed something called angular
material and so
if you take a look at the app component
i've put in an app dashboard and so if
we ran
a command like ng-serve what we would
see is a
normal dashboard of an application
that's coming from angular material so
we've got a few dependencies installed
we've got a few
other things installed and all that
should just be coming to you kind of
automatically
so here we go this is just the default
blank dashboard
and so even though we haven't written a
ton of code we've got a application up
and running
and it's pulling in a ton of code right
we're pulling in the features of angular
necessary for these animations for these
menus for these dialogues
as well as for all of this content
around this dashboard that a user could
interact with and engage with and so
the first thing i want to do in order to
make my application fast as possible is
i really want to understand my
application
so we're going to make a couple changes
within our build configuration
in the angular.json file so what we're
going to do is we're going to find the
in your json file you're going to find
this directly in the root of your
application
and what we're going to do is we're
going to find in the production build
settings
we're going to change two settings here
we're going to say source map i'm
going to change that from false to true
as well as
in our named chunks we're going to turn
that on to true
what source map does is this will
actually take my application and map
all of the generated javascript that
comes out of the build
and map it back into the code that that
javascript came from
so if some of the generated code came
from angular material we'll see that if
it came from angular itself we'll see
that
and we'll even see things like the
generated javascript being mapped
back to my html and into the application
code that i'm writing for all the
components that i'm creating
so source maps are a really great way
for you to understand
what's going on in your application and
the relationship between what happens
in the code you write in the ide and the
code that's being delivered to your
users
and so there's a lot of steps that we
end up taking along that way right
there's the angular compiler that takes
that html and turns it into javascript
but there's also other steps that we do
like optimizations where we'll change
some of the property names
you've got bundling so that we get all
of this javascript coming down as a
single kind of cohesive bundle
that makes sense to browsers and so
source map allows us to follow that path
follow that process
and give us really good insights and so
what we can do is having made these two
changes
we can actually now go and run a ng
build
dash dash prod what that will do is that
will
create a production build of our
application which is normally what you
ship down to browsers
but because we've turned on source maps
and we've turned on name chunks
we'll actually see the javascript and be
able to analyze those chunks
and so we're also going to be using
another tool today called source map
explorer
there's a bunch of other tools out there
that developers use to analyze bundle
size and chunk size
but what we on the angular team actually
really strongly recommend is you only
use source map explorer because
there are tools out there like webpack
bundle analyzer that categorically
misrecognize some of those steps within
our process and so
we've done that production build and now
whenever you want to actually take a
look at what a
source map looks like we can just run
source map explorer if you don't have
this installed you can just install it
globally
you're in global ad source map explorer
or you can install it local to your
project whichever makes sense to you
just go ahead and do that
and what we'll do is we'll run source
map explorer
and we will pass it in the javascript
file that we
want to analyze and so we can see that
we've got our disk folder here and we're
going to look at the
es2015 version of our javascript
so if we run that it's going to pop open
a web browser and we're going to see
this visual interactive
story about our application so we can
see our overall bundle size
in terms of minified but not compressed
javascript so it'll actually be a little
bit smaller when it goes over the
network
uh we have about four uh 152 kilobytes
of application
and what's really really helpful here is
that you can see where that bundle size
is coming from so you can see
animations is 64 kilobytes angular
material is
about 56 kilobytes we've got things like
http
where we might actually need these
things and we might not even know that
they're in our bundle we might have
forgotten at some point along the way so
you can see i'm pulling in forms and
http if we actually go into our
application we
now that we know that those things are
there we can say hey i don't actually
need that for this dashboard right like
we're not
if we look at the content i'm showing
here there's no form data here there's
no data coming from the internet
and i can go into my app module and i
could pull those out right so i'll just
comment these out because we don't need
http or forms
and what should happen is when i do my
next production bundle
all of that code is going to be left out
so we're going to be able to see that
our bundle size will come down from
around 450 kb to a little bit less than
that which is really really nice and it
should actually be
exactly leaving out the size of the hp
bundle and the size of the forms bundle
and so source maps are one of the best
tools in your toolbox and
we really recommend that every developer
be using source mavics for using this
on a regular basis to understand your
application especially when you're doing
any sort of performance optimization
now let's say that you are looking at
your bundle and you're saying it's still
too big but i need all of those features
i need all of those capabilities
fortunately the angular cli offers a lot
of really smart capabilities one of
those capabilities
is being able to take an application and
build out lazy loaded modules and so
let's actually go ahead and do this and
so i'm going to use the cli here
and i'm going to say ng which is the
angular command and i'm going to say
generate
module and i'm going to give it a
root module that it's going to connect
back to so what we're going to do is
we're going to create
a separate part of our application where
we can pull in the features that we need
and just leave all that code outside of
the main bundle and so we're going to
generate a module here
and i'll just link it back to the module
known as app module which is the root of
my application
and now i'm going to give it a route and
so what this does is it automatically
wires up this module
to be lazy loaded whenever a user hits
that route and so we'll just make for
example an about page
and so what this is going to do it's
going to generate a module called
about module it's going to be able to
route to it and then it's going to give
me an about component
so we can see all of that in our source
code so let's just close all these files
and we're going to see it created a new
about folder with our
new module and our new code and so if we
do another production build
what we'll actually see because we
turned on named
chunks we'll actually get out now not
only a main
chunk a main module we're also going to
get out an about module we can
see and independently verify the size of
that module and independently verify
what the dependencies of that module are
doing to the overall bundle size of our
application
and so what you'll see is that by
default an angular module is really
really small it's very very thin it
doesn't add a ton of bundle size your
application
it's almost always the dependencies that
you are pulling in as a developer the
features that you are reaching out
for and what anywhere will do
intelligently based on the
where you do the imports will lazy load
and split that code so
if you remember we pulled http and forms
out of our main chunk
we could actually now pull that in and
so you can see we've generated a
let's just clear this out let's take a
look in our disk folder here
you can see we've got a main chunk and
now we've got
this nice new about module as you can
see
in the es2015 version our about module
is only about 1.1 k of code so it's just
that about component because it doesn't
have any dependencies
but if we add back in more dependencies
into that
chunk if we wanted to pull in for
example angular material into that about
module
then it's going to pull in that code but
it's going to do it very very
intelligently it's going to lazy load
all of that code so
if you haven't set up lazy loading
before it's really really easy just
generate a new module with that command
that i showed where we generate a module
and we hang it onto the routing
structure of our application
all right next up i want to talk a
little bit about what happens after we
build an application after we've been
building it out and we've added more and
more features
it's very very easy to backslide one of
the things that the chrome team has seen
consistently is that even applications
that spend a ton of time
building great performance into their
apps tend to backslide because we as
developers we want to add more features
we want to push
more functionality to our users and that
often comes with more dependencies
which sometimes we don't realize is
negatively affecting our bundle size and
so
one of the features that's built into
the angular cli is called bundle
budgets and so again if we go back into
our angularjson so let's search for that
we can see this nice little budgets
section and what this does is it allows
you to set several different budgets for
your application
and by default we give you two out of
the box we give you an initial budget
so this is the javascript that it takes
to
load the initial page of your
application so right now
we are warning at two megabytes so we'll
see a warning as part of our build if
our application is over two megabytes
and our build will actually error out if
it's more than five megabytes and so
those are very very conservative
defaults we recommend you turn those
as small as you can to really just give
yourself a knowledge of when you're
increasing your bundle size
it's a conscious choice rather than an
accident you'll see we also have a few
other types of budgets including
any component style so what this says is
that any scoped styles to a component
we want to keep those under 6 kilobytes
and we are going to error out if they
become above 10 kilobytes and there's
a few more that you can see if you just
take a look in your id
you've got all scripts so that's just
what is the total sum of all the scripts
in my application
uh any script so any individual script
should be bigger than this
uh the whole bundle overall all those
sorts of things so we've got a whole
bunch of different features that
allow you to really take control and
understand and prevent
bundle size increases so that's a really
really helpful tool so
those are some of the top things that
you should be doing to keep your
application as fast as possible
but one of the best things you can do
that doesn't take a lot of work
is actually staying up to date with
angular so if we jump back to the
terminal here
what we'll see is that i actually
created this angular application on an
old version of angular
it is running version 8. so version 8 is
not the latest version version
nine as of this filming is uh the latest
version and version 10 is coming out
but it's always the same so if you are
on an out of date version of angular
your bundle size is going to be bigger
and slower than it needs to be because
what happens is
over time every time we do a release the
angular team is looking at what can we
do better
with the release of version 8 we
actually made a huge step forward
by automatically doing something called
differential loading where because we
have this opinionated control of the
entire tool chain
we understand how to make your
production bundles and so what we did is
we
said hey modern browsers are capable of
loading javascript differently
than legacy browsers that don't support
something called es modules
and so using that knowledge you can
actually conditionally force
modern browsers to load modern
javascript and legacy browsers to the
legacy javascript and this is a really
nice schism
that allows you to have two bundles
that really gives you the best of both
worlds where you can ship the smallest
fastest javascript to modern browsers
that support the most recent
capabilities
like classes like modules all those
sorts of things and you can leave
a older legacy bundle for browsers that
don't have that kind of support so we
actually did this out of the box by
default so
you notice when we were doing those
builds we were actually getting the
two javascript bundles for each of the
files so we had an about module 2015 and
we had an about module es5
and so again this is one of the changes
that the angular angular team did behind
the scenes
without having you to make you change
any of the code in your application and
this is something we do every single
release and so what we're going to do
now is we're going to make our
application as
fresh as possible so we're going to
update to the latest version of angular
and we're going to
automatically get more improvements to
our bundle size this is something that
just happens
every time you keep your application up
to date using angular and so
we're going to again use the ng cli
command and we're going to use ng
update and we're going to update our
application in a couple stages first
we're going to update
the angular core packages so core and
the core package as well as the cli
package and then what we're going to do
is we're going to go and update our
dependencies so we're going to as two
steps to make sure that we don't
accidentally enter a mistake or an error
where application is no longer
compatible with one of those
dependencies so
let's go ahead and get this started so
i'm going to run ng update
and we're going to do is we're going to
pass it angular cli
and angular core now if you are on an
even older version
what we do is we recommend that you go
one version at a time just so we can
apply things cleanly
and if you want to do that for example
if you are in version 6 you want to go
to version 7 you can just say
at 7 and that will just do that for you
but we're going to go all the way
from version 8 up to version 9 which is
the latest so i'm going to run this
command
and theoretically things should work
there's a few
places where this might fail if your
repository isn't clean
then what should happen is we're going
to throw this warning which is what
we're seeing right now
repository is not clean please commit
because what we want is we want you to
have a very clean history
so that you actually know what the
angular update process did because
this isn't like a normal ng update where
we're just modifying the node modules of
your project
we're actually making changes to your
application so that you stay compatible
with angular
and the reason we're able to do this is
because the angular team at google
we have thousands of projects across
google that are not run by our team
that are using angular and it's actually
according to google policy our
responsibility for keeping those
applications working
as we make breaking changes to angular
and so in only way that we can scale
this at google is to build really
great automation and really great
tooling and so what we did is we baked
that same sort of tooling into the
public world
into this ng update command so whenever
we need to change a method name whenever
we need to deprecate something
we're going to try and update your
application as best we can and so that's
why we always make sure that you want to
have a clean history so we'll just get
add everything
[Music]
commit that and now we should be able to
run our update command
so again what's happening behind the
scenes is it's i'm going to be
downloading installing the latest
version of angular cli and then it's
going to be
updating the packages in my application
and changing my code where needed
and so if there's any sort of migrations
what should happen is while you're doing
the update process
it's going to report what migrations
it's doing so you can see
in your workspace migration so it made a
few changes to the workspace layout so
you can see it updated my angularjs and
followed up to my tsconfig.app
it updated the package.json so it's
making all of these migrations even ones
that don't really have
any changes to my app it's still double
checking all those things
so that we know that my application is
going to keep working now there's a
couple other places that you can look
for the latest
information you'll notice here at the
very very bottom of the update
it actually says for more information
please see this link and so we actually
have guides on
what changes we're making behind the
scenes with every version of angular so
you can know about things like
deprecations you can know about things
like removals
and changes to the way that apis work
the other one that i want to point you
out
to would be update.angular.io
so behind the scenes when you ran
ng-update we made a lot of changes to
your project and so
if you actually wanted to see what you
need to do you can just go to the update
guide you can say show me how to update
and we'll say
oh make sure you're on the latest
version here make sure you're using this
version of node
it walks you through the changes that
are going to affect you as a developer
and you can even tune this based on the
number and amount of features and the
depth and complexity of your usage of
angular
because most applications don't need to
care about all the changes we're making
under the hood but
let's say you have a large application
maybe you have several hundred
components you have component libraries
you're using things like universal
you can check these boxes and what we'll
do is it will show you
all of the information about the update
all the changes we're making behind the
scenes
so you can have a full complete
understanding of what's going on the
other way you can do it is if you just
take a look at the git history
you can now go in and see what all the
changes we made were so for example
when we moved to version 9 we turned on
ahead of time compilation
by default so that's going to make your
build a lot faster you can see that
we've
installed all the dependencies and not
just on angular we've also installed
things like rxjs to the latest version
we've updated your components so that
they actually continue working as we
make
changes to angular so this is really
really powerful and then we can actually
do a test to see
if this works so let's just run on ng
serve and we can say
yes let's let google analytics track
some of our cli usage anonymously
and what will happen is when we return
back to the browser window
we're going to get the latest version of
angular and our app is generally just
going to keep working
and then the way that this really
affects you is not only keeping you up
to date as a developer making sure
you're using best practices
but again it's also going to improve the
performance of your application one of
the things that you're going to see
is that every time we make an updated
angle we're trying to look for ways to
make it you're more tree shakeable to
make
your build system better and so there's
lots of experimentation lots of ideation
going on there because
the state of bundlers in javascript are
not static
webpack keeps getting better rollup
keeps getting better terser keeps
getting better
and these tools are changing and they're
evolving and the way that they relate to
each other is changing and so
what we do is as the angular team we're
trying to stay on top of that for you
and so let's go ahead and refresh and if
we take a look in the dev tools we
should see we are now on
the latest version of angular so 919 at
the writing but whenever you use ng
update it's just going to move you to
the latest version it's going to do that
automatically for you
so that you are staying up to date
staying fresh staying fast
so once you've updated angular and
you've updated the cli uh by core in
common
now what i'm going to do is i'm going to
go and update all the other packages so
if you take a look for example
um we did not in our package.json we
didn't update
the cdk or we didn't update angular
material and so we're going to do one
more ng update command
to update anywhere material and your cdk
you can do this with any of your
dependencies a lot of dependencies are
starting to support these
automatic migrations this is something
we've been pushing very hard for in the
[Music]
ecosystem
all right let's just run that ng update
angular material and uscdk command again
and again it's fetching the latest
version of those packages it's updating
their dependencies in your package.json
and then it's going to execute any
migrations that you need to be on the
latest version
and i think we're going to run ng-serve
one last time and we will see that our
entire application
kept on working and our bundle size
should have gotten a little bit better
and again it's doing a little bit of
compiling ahead of time
uh generally this is a temporary thing
that you're going to see with ivy and
with version 9
as we do this extra compilation that's
really to offer the latest version
of angular and the latest features of
angular while still staying compatible
with the rest of the ecosystem
so this is just a extra compilation step
that the angular team does to optimize
things
all right as soon as this compilation is
complete what we're going to see is
we're going to be on the latest version
of angular
and again we updated the package json so
just all the dependencies
including removing things like hammer.js
and our application should just keep
working yep there it is
we have a great dashboard just like we
had before right in the beginning
everything works everything animates
we're now in the latest version of
angular we're now in the latest version
material in the cdk
and our application is as fast as we can
be because we're budgeting we're making
sure that we're
understanding our application making
sure it doesn't grow over time we're
analyzing the application bundle size
with source maps
and we're doing things like lazy loading
so that we only make users pay for the
features that they're using at the
current time
that's going to be it for us thank you
so much for watching and have a
wonderful day